now you want me to show you how
astonishing how amazing God's true word
is you want me to show you how
is in comparison to Muhammad and his God
2200 years before the Quran this is what
the god of Moses said to Moses this is
what the god of Moses said to Moses 2200
years before the Quran brother if you
don't mind post Deuteronomy 20
Deuteronomy 21 and this is in my article
veres 10-4 Deuteronomy 21: 10-4 this is
in my
article I'm want to read to you what
even Scholars say about this passage
Deuteronomy 21: 10- 14 guys pay
attention Deuteronomy 21: 10- 14 read
this guys the god of Moses 2200 years
before Muhammad look what he said
when thou goest forth when thou goest
forth to war against thine enemies and
the Lord thy God hath delivered them
into thine hands and thou Hast taken
them captive right now watch this and
you seeth among them you see among the
captives a beautiful woman and has a
desire unto her that thou wouldest have
her to thy wife that you want to marry
her then Thou shalt bring her bring her
home into thine house watch she shall
shave her head and pair her Nails shave
her head and pair her nails right then
Thou shalt bring her home to thine house
and she shall shave her head and pair
her nails she shall put the reignment of
her captivity off take her clothes off
in which you took her captive so she
doesn't be reminded of her captivity and
shall remain in thy house and she will
bewail mourn her father mother for a
full month you don't touch her for a
month and after that thou shalt go into
her and be her husband and she shall be
thy wife she's not your sex captive you
don't sleep with her and then sell her
off you desire her you honor her and
marry her and make her a
wife verse 14 and it shall be if thou
have no Delight in her let's say after
you marry her and it doesn't work out
then thou shall let her go whether she
will wherever she wants to go send her
wherever she wants to go but Thou shalt
not sell her at all for money Thou shalt
not make Merchant I of her because thou
has humbled her wow do you see the
difference between the god of Moses and
the god of Muhammad you find a beautiful
captive woman you take her home change
her clothes the clothes that you that
she was taken captive in shave her hair
trim her nails signs of mourning give
her a whole month to be alone to
mourn and after that month you marry her
and you don't dishonor her and if it
doesn't work out like others isite women
maybe not working you divorce her send
her where she wants but she's not your
property you don't sell
her with numbers 3117 to 18 I'll have
fun with that in a minute you hear me
there yes and that's another thing the
only reason why Muslims will wait before
sleeping with a captive woman Miss V I'm
glad you mentioned
it the only reason why a Muslim will
wait before marrying a captive woman is
to see if she's pregnant so that if
she's pregnant they know they're not the
father the child because then she
becomes if they get her pregnant she
becomes umed the mother of a child their
child
right so that's the only reason why they
lay hands off of her so if we take a
captive woman I'm a Muslim it's not I
can't sleep with right away wait to see
if she's pregnant because if she's not
sleep with her because in case you get
her pregnant now she's the mother of
your child although even though she's
your
captive so notice in Islam you don't
wait in order to give her time to mourn
that's not the reason she doesn't matter
you wait to make sure you she's not
pregnant by you so if she's pregnant by
her husband then you let her give birth
to the child whereas in Deuteronomy you
give the woman a full month for the
specific reason of allowing her to
mourn and it's not talking about captive
women who are
married okay guys do you see the
difference between the god of Moses and
the god of Muhammad the god of Moses
says when you take a captive woman you
do not rape her you don't have sex with
her and sell her off you honor her by
letting her mourn the dead for a whole
month shave her head pair her nails
change her clothes and then marry her
and love her as a wife giving her the
status of an Israelite
woman okay brother I'll answer it
where's the brother that ask me the
question is he a Christian
brother let's see where is he I'll
answer if he's a Christian I'll answer
the question the Christian brother ask
me about numbers 31178 soan my brother I
love you can you number one let's look
at numbers 31178 since that came up let
me let me answer it so on let me answer
it for you
brother okay let me answer let's
see numbers 311
1718 I want to give you a verse that I
want you to live by okay I want you
remember this verse it's Titus 115 to
the pure all things are pure but to the
corrupt and unbelieving nothing is pure
their very minds and consciences are
corrupt someone who is purified by the
blood of Jesus when he reads numbers 311
1718 not just 18 the AL numbers are
kicking in numbers 311
1718 they will understand this is Mercy
and compassion but when a muhammadin
who's defiled like their Prophet reads
it he sees nothing but lust and sexual
perversion numbers 311 17-
18 now therefore kill every male among
the little ones and kill every woman who
has known man intimately but all the
girls who have not known man intimately
spare for yourselves all the girls who
have not known man intimately spare for
yourselves now let's read vers 18 can
you show me where it says that these
girls you're sparing is for sex
understand why God ordered the slaughter
of the moabites the medit and the women
who had known men do you understand the
context or
no because to understand numbers 31 you
got to read numbers 25 and numbers 31
together the reason why God commanded
the slaughter is because the moabit
medanite women enticed the Israelites to
commit sexual ories with them in
worshiping
ba you with me there read numbers 25
numbers
31 and this was also done at the
instigation of balam bam the false
prophet that's why he got killed too
okay understand the context a group of
moabit medanite women enticed Israelites
to have sexual origies with them
perverted sexual relations in the
worship of the false god baale Bal so
what God is saying is punish them
especially the women who are married who
known man
intimately who were used of the devil to
entice isite men to defile themselves
and sin against God punish them but
spare the young girls do you know why
because the young girls are innocent
they didn't entice the men to sexual
orgies and worshiping ba so what was an
act of Mercy on God's part when it comes
to a Muslim in the hands of Muslim
becomes a text for sexual
perversion do you see why Titus 115
applies to them Titus 115 to the pure
all things are pure but to the corrupt
and unbelieving nothing is pure their
very minds and consciences are
corrupt what was an act of Mercy spare
these young girls they're innocent they
haven't enticed them to sexual ories and
worshiping bow spare them adopt them
into Israelite Community teach them the
ways of Yahweh and when they're mature
they'll marry Israelite men and have
children for Israel as they're now
engrafted into the Commonwealth of
Israel but all the girls those are the
little ones who have not known men
intimately spare for yourselves
spare for some so you can defile them
sexually no bring them into the
Commonwealth of Israel raise them as
your daughters introduce them to the god
of Israel and when they're mature and
they marry an Israelite men they will
produce children for the god of
Israel you understand the passage is
saying spare them not because you can
sexually ravage them as an act of Mercy
on these young girls who did nothing to
entice this white men into sexual
perverted acts ories and worship of Bale
did you got
that thank you Elias God bless you
secondly so do you know how I know they
can't defile those young girls do you
know how I know they can't defile those
young girls because the same God of
Moses also told Moses what you read in
Deuteronomy 21:10 to14 and what did God
say she can't be a little girl because
now no the word is different there was
little girls in Deuteronomy it's women
meaning women mature enough mature
enough that you marry them not have sex
with them defile them and sell them
off so so now let's read Deuteronomy 21:
10-
14 Deuteronomy 21 verses 10 to 14 let's
read that again we need to know our
Bible folks why do you think I spent 99%
of my streams on Bible topics because
the level of biblical illiteracy is
disgusting among Christians but
Christians will flock to YouTube
sessions and live streams about Muhammad
hundreds and hundreds oh yeah Muhammad
the perfect the Holy Spirit started
teaching me by throwing me into the
lions then and having Lions trying to
tear me to shreds by attacking my faith
and me crying out to the Holy Spirit
please give me answers to these attacks
on the Bible because the Bible is your
word and if you give me answers I
surrender to you to use me to then bless
Christians so they can have answers
that's
how exactly Pedro if anyone truly knows
the Bible and understands it and is
aware of the massive overwhelming
historical archaeological scientific
facts they will be more in love with
Jesus than ever before by the power of
the Holy Spirit Deuteronomy 2110 to4 how
do I know that isites cannot ravish
these young girls because the same God
of Moses said this to Moses just because
it's written later doesn't mean it
wasn't known earlier orally because what
Moses wrote down he would have preached
orally he would have told them the laws
and then written them
down okay so what does he say when you
go out to the battle against your
enemies and the Lord your God deliver
them into your hands and you take them
away captive and see among the captive a
beautiful woman now go look at the
Hebrew it's not the same word girl in
numbers 31 here it's women why because
it's a woman who's mature enough to be
married those were young girls they were
minors that you take in treat as
daughters and raise them making them
part of the Commonwealth of Israel when
they're mature then you marry them off
and see among the captives of beautiful
women and have a desire for her and
would take her as a wife for yourself
then you shall bring her home to your
house and she shall shave her head and
trim her nails she shall also remove the
clothes of her captivity and shall
remain in your house and mourn her
father and mother a full month and after
you after that you may go into and do
what go into do what rape
them no be her husband shall be your
wife it shall be if you're not pleased
with her then you shall let her go
wherever she wishes but you shall
certainly not sell her for money you
shall not mistreat her because you have
humbled
her you caught it go read the text here
let me give it to you what's the word
here for woman let's see hold so the
only reason why I stop this is related
to the Quran that's the only reason why
I'm addressing numbers 311 1718 it is
related to the Quran so you see how
amazing the god of Moses is who's The
God Who became Jesus of Nazareth unlike
the god of Muhammad remember this law of
Moses 2200 years before Muhammad and I'm
going to read to you what the scholars
say about this command in light of its
historical context I'm not done yet but
hold
on I'm not done yet wait so thank God
the Bible's being included as well
okay let me just let's let's look at the
words you know I'm not making it up and
I trust the Holy Spirit to give me
Clarity of thought by his grace and
mercy for the GL of
Jesus make no mistakes and save me from
error
okay is is the plural of is see is the
plural of is is I'm sorry is the plural
of is because is comes from ish here it
is okay take here just let's let's go
here is the P of is which comes from ish
that's where my confusion came in please
Holy Spirit save me and illuminate me
not to make any mistakes to glorify
Christ now let's see the other word here
by the way the word is is the word often
translated as wife notice here you'll
see the word go here and look it says
the young woman young notice the
qualifier
young that's why it's girls because they
are young notice that qualifier is not
in Deuteronomy 2110
to14 okay there it goes right there the
Young young woman okay so when you go
and see go look at the word young
woman here it goes here's the word so
you know I'm not making it up here you
go little ones little ones so they're
not women they're Little Women
girls little ones go see how that word
is used little ones there it
goes this exact form of the word
here it's used in several places it
means little ones they're little ones
not making it
up so so the difference is in
Deuteronomy 21 it's Isa iset
plural but without the qualifier young
these women are said to be young the
qualifiers there so they're girls not
women
why the difference because in
Deuteronomy 21 they women they're mature
enough to get married here they're girls
young young women young girls why they
are too
young
premature immature I don't want to use
the term immature because I'm not saying
they're mentally
handicapped and therefore you show them
Mercy by bring them into the household
because they were not guilty in enticing
the Israelites to commit sexual orgies
with them in the worship of
Baal so does everyone stand the point
the on 21 they're said to be women not
girls numbers not 31 they are girls
because they're said to be little young
women that qualifier little young there
is no little young in Deuteronomy 21 it
doesn't say when you find a little girl
no a woman ISAT plural of is here
numbers 31 it's qualified what kind of
women young women Little Women meaning
little girls